welcome back whenever I start running
out of time I rush things and I most
probably confuse you so let me go over
that last example one more time so I
said I have a completely flair fair coin
and I'm going to flip it twice and I
want to know the probability that I get
heads in both times all right well we
already know that the probability that I
get heads the first time is 1/2 there's
1/2 chance I get heads the first time
and there's 1/2 chance that I get tails
the first time and then I'm going to
flip again and let's say in this world
there's a 1/2 chance that we enter into
this reality where the first flip is
heads and then in that world I'm going
to flip a coin again and I know that
there's a 1/2 chance of heads and this
is the second flip and 1/2 chance of
tails and I know in this other world
I'll just draw it just so we can figure
out maybe other probabilities I know
that there's a 1/2 chance of heads so
this is for the second flip and I know
that there's a 1/2 chance of tails the
second flip and just so you know this is
called a probability tree and in general
it really it works excellent if you
don't have you know if you're not
dealing with huge numbers if you're not
dealing with you know I'm doing a
hundred trials or I am doing you know or
the probabilities get really messy or
there's in each trial there's you know
50 different circumstances that it can
occur in when you're doing with you know
they're in this situation there's two
branches per you could say per node so
there's not that many circumstances that
can occur on each trial and we're not
doing that many trials so it's pretty
manageable and in these situations the
probability tree works really well you
can never get overwhelmed with the
information then and I'll show you will
do some pretty complicated examples
using probability tree there's no reason
why I actually circle that with yellow I
just happened to switch do but anyway
just so you know this was the first
trial that's the first trial and then
this is the second trial this is the
second trial so we want to know we want
to know the probability of getting here
right because we got heads on the first
trial heads on the second well we know
that there was a 1/2 chance of getting
there
and then we know of that one half chance
or you know half the times we got here
half of those times we would get there
so the probability of getting there is
1/2 times 1/2 which is equal to 1/4
another way of thinking about it is each
of these scenarios so this is this this
is a scenario heads heads where I could
get a heads and a heads this is the
scenario heads tails this is the
scenario tails heads right you're going
to tail then you get a head and this is
the scenario tails tails and all of
these are equally probable scenarios
right there's no reason why one is more
likely than the other and so we have
four equally probable scenarios so the
total of equally probable scenarios is
four and then what's the and then how
many of these equally probable scenarios
in which company for these equal
probably scenarios is our is our
probability or our event true well it's
one of them heads heads so it's one for
so that's another way of viewing it and
another way you could view it is if we
did this trial a hundred times if we did
this 100 times 50 of the times my first
my first flip will be heads right and
then of those 50 times 25 of those times
right half of those of those trials
where I got 50 the first time will be
heads again and so of 25 out of the
total hundred trials we'll end up with
heads heads or this is 25% chance I want
to show you that all of these are pretty
much equivalent but I want your brain to
kind of connect and make sure that it
that it understands everything so now
that we've drawn this probably I don't
want to go to waste so let me give you
another circumstance what is what is the
probability what is the probability that
I get at least let's probably get one
heads and one tail and notice I'm not
saying that it has to be in that order
you know it could be tails heads or
heads tails so this could be let me
write that down this could be this is
equal to the probability of tails heads
plus
the probability of heads tails or we
could write that as and this is kind of
with set theory notation but it's good
to be familiar with all of these it's
the probability of getting tail heads or
this you looking thing it means or in
set theory or the probability of getting
heads tails right you eat we can get
tails heads or heads tails and either of
these we're getting one heads and one
tails so what's that probability well we
can just look at all of the outcomes and
and we know that there are four paths
equally probable outcomes and then how
many of these is our is the event that
we want true well it's one two right so
there's a 2/4 or equal 1/2 chance when
we do both of these flips we get at
least one heads and at least one tails
and I think it's a good time now that
you know we've drawn this tree and we've
talked about you know two flips in a row
up to realize that these are mutually
exclusive events the reason why we can
multiply the probability of the first
event times the probability of the
second event is because the probability
of getting a heads the second time is
completely independent of whether I got
a heads the first time and that might be
obvious to you but sometimes it isn't
you know some people feel that if they
got 5 heads in a row that they're more
likely to get a tails on the sixth time
and and but what we know from experience
really is that no it's not like the coin
knows that you got five heads in a row
and then it says oh boy I better give
Sal a tails now just to kind of make up
for all the five heads you got it's
equally probable to get a heads again so
that's just something to keep in mind
it's amazing how just human beings
psychologically you feel that if you
have a big streak of heads that you're
due for a tails but your probability of
getting that tails does not increase
although I will if you keep doing it
your probability of getting eventually
get the more times you do it the
probability of getting a tails does
increase and I'll show you that soon
that last statement probably can
confused you and I probably shouldn't
have said it but
so let's do an example now that we know
that in mutually conclusive events you
can just multiply the probabilities so
let's say I have a fair coin and let's
what's the probability of getting five
heads in a row five heads in a row in a
row well I have a 1/2 chance of getting
heads the first time then of those
another 1/2 then another 1/2 so it's 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2
and that equals 1/2 to the fifth power
and that's equal to 1 over 2 to the
fifth power and what's that's 1 over 32
that's the probability of getting 5
heads in a row what's the probability of
I don't know what's the probability of
getting what's the probability of
getting let's say I were to flip a coin
seven times
so what let's say I flip a coin out of
seven times out of seven times what's
the probability of not getting any heads
not getting any and I'm gonna switch
colors just for the hell of it any heads
well that might seem a little bit more
comic book on fluted to you but but just
think about it
the probability of out of the seven
flips of not getting any heads that is
equal what has to be true then we got
all tails in that's equal to the
probability of getting seven tails in a
row seven tails in a row and what is
that equal well the tails are equally
likely to the heads so that would be 1/2
to the seventh power and that equals
what is that 2 so it'll be 4 times 1/32
right because we so that's equal to 1
over 128 and use an experiment to do is
it maybe in your classroom or if you
have a large group of people together
you know maybe
maybe 128 people or you know some large
number of people and you make everyone
flip a coin multiple times but by the
end of you know five or six or seven
flips they'll probably be and later on
will actually figure out the probability
that there is someone who has a streak
but they'll probably someone who has a
very long streak of heads or tails and
that person will probably think that
there is something magical about what is
going on in their life at that moment
and it's important to realize that if
you have a if you have a large room if
you have a room of 500 people someone's
going to be getting there's a likelihood
and we haven't figured that out yet but
just given that you have a 128 chance of
getting seven seven heads or seven tails
in a row someone's going to get it if
you have 500 people flipping coins but
that person since they just view their
own reality they think that you know
today is their lucky day and they think
that they're on some type of streak and
they should go to Vegas but that's just
something that you should think about
because you know probability can can
often play with our brains but anyway I
have 10 seconds left so I will see you
in the next video